hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
if x is equal to one minus the square
root of five
then x to the power of four minus four x
cubed plus four x squared is what value
you have two minutes to solve this
problem and you cannot use a calculator
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so your first instinct might be to
directly substitute x is equal to one
minus square root of five
but if you do that it'll actually be
pretty complicated
direct calculation is tedious and there
are many steps in which you can make a
mistake
so i would instead suggest that you
simplify this first by factoring
first we'll take a look at these x terms
we can factor out x squared
then we're left with a quadratic
equation which we can further factor
this is equal to the quantity x minus 2
squared
we then further simplify by taking the
exponent outside this grouping
now let's substitute
x is equal to 1 minus the square root of
5.
the second factor will simplify to be
negative square root of five minus one
we'll now flip the terms in the first
factor
the reason we're doing this is that we
get a product of a sum and a difference
which will be equal to a difference of
squares
so this will be equal to negative square
root of 5 squared minus 1 squared
the first term will simplify to be 5 and
then we have 5 minus 1 which is equal to
4.
4 squared is then equal to 16 and that's
our answer
the lesson is that it sometimes helps to
think before you start calculating
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube thanks for watching and
thanks for your support
[Music]